hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Walking Dead episode 12 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet this is basically like the
Suicide Squad episode of Walking Dead
really the big storylines in this
episode were riggan was shown as the
carnival sort of like the positive
storyline and then the frustration of
Rosita storyline until she comes to the
conclusion that she's just going to do
whatever she needs to do and form the
suicide squad so they can go kill negan
so there's a new round of the walkie
dead giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video it's a $20 Amazon gift
card so let's start top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs so number 10 rick and
michonne go on a mom and dad road trip
just to have some alone time don't come
a-knockin when this bands of rock n
because Michonne will stab you in the
face it was so fun I love the way they
cut it with that from music it's just so
intense but it's really hopeful because
now they're like oh this is fun we're
going to find the stuff we need we're
going to kick ass we have a plan we know
what we need to do so they are in
full-on vacation mode they even spot a
deer that gets away but leads them to
something even better
number 9 they find the carnival behind
the army facility so they see the badges
they realize this is some sort of army
installation there was something fun
going on out back but something terrible
happened and it sounds like it was at
the beginning of the apocalypse or like
something a long time ago happened that
was really terrible they find the ground
littered with giant shell casings so
they get really excited the idea finding
some really big guns and automatically
the music starts to chill out a little
bit so you start to wonder when the rug
is going to get pulled out from under
them it eventually does it takes a while
to get there but any time you fall into
a pot of gold like this like oh my god
there might be a ton of really awesome
guns here you just wonder what the twist
is going to be number eight though the
way they balance it is with Rosita
storyline where she just progressively
gets more and more fed up she thinks she
finds a gun it's a water pistol she gets
herself all bloodied up she won't even
hear anything from Terra should I leave
me alone I'm just going to be crazy
intense right now I want to keep my scar
like she's trying to help her heal her
scar but it's almost like Rosie the
either wants to keep the scar as a
reminder of what happened or maybe she
thinks she's going to die really soon so
it doesn't even matter like why even
bother to heal any of your scars if
you're just going to die tomorrow
but number seven back in happy town just
like the funniest moment ever they find
the carnival out back and just as
Michonne is like shooting some of the
bottles at the carnival like it's a
total game for them they fall through
the roof and Michonne just starts a
laughing off of camera it was so weird
how they tried to lighten the episode
with that Michonne rigged storyline and
then they would go back to Rosita and
she was just super hardcore like she
even confronts Gabriel you don't know
[ __ ] about [ __ ] and he's like well me
not knowing anything and stopping you
from killing negan is the reason you're
alive so you're welcome to be pissed off
at me about that but you're alive and
you need to decide what you're going to
do next you need to make the decision so
that's kind of where it syncs up with
rick and michonne storyline where
Michonne asked that question what comes
next like we need to figure this out we
defeat negan there needs to be a new
world order you should be in charge
and of course Rick true to form is like
no way do not want to be in charge of
everything so we'll see how this
storyline plays out because it seems
like what they're setting up is more of
Rick just sort of getting over that hump
raise like you know I don't want to be a
leader I don't want to be responsible
for all these people swinging back
around a crazy beard Rick by the end of
the season deciding hey I'm going to be
in charge this is what we're going to do
I have a plan so Rick can be all over
the place but he gave her speech at the
end of the episode that I'll explain
which is basically like okay we need to
move forward but it doesn't have to be
me it can be anybody else
the only real moment of nervousness that
I had during their storyline number six
was when Rick says they could go back
early like they're enjoying Mack Chilean
cheese just totally chilling out having
sex having like this really formal
dinner date with candles and you start
to wonder if they're losing focus on
what's happening right now the task at
hand in thinking more about what's
happening weeks months years down the
road stuff that doesn't even matter
because we haven't got there yet so I
feel like the whole point of that scene
where they're just like whatever we do
we do it together is it's been sort of
re committing to each other like
whatever ends up happening they'll stay
together they just want to make you feel
good about that
they did this really weird thing in the
episode where they would vacillate
between really serious stuff and really
silly stuff between different storylines
so like after a Rick and Michonne get
super serious about the future they
swing back to number five baby Judith
giving Terra a therapy session the look
on her face
priceless to baby Judith could give a
crap about Oceanside all this business
she's like I just want to play with my
toys why are you talking to me what's
going on here
so as silly as this moment was I was
happy they included the scene because it
explains why Tara conveniently forgot
about Oceanside because they're trying
to get more gun but she's been quiet
this whole time like Rosita at the
beginning of the episode is like we need
more guns in terror just keeps her mouth
shut like she just completely forgot you
spent all this time at a place where all
they have is guns like they have more
guns than they know what to do with her
whole thing is that she just feels like
the Oceanside people won't want to have
anything to do with their war on Meighan
and then Rick won't leave without the
gun so they'll reach an impasse and
it'll just wind up with everybody
killing each other sort of swinging back
to the carnival trying to get the guns
they actually do have right in front of
them number four Rick and Michonne clear
everything out but just like the rest of
the episode it sort of swings from being
really silly to getting really serious
like when you think that Rick might end
up dying so Rick makes this big joke
about how he's going to let Michonne
kill all the walkers while he plugs the
hole in the fence
it goes terribly they get stuck they
wind up splitting the group and
everything looks like it's going to be
really good they have this really cool
montages than just going to town on all
these walkers but then Rick spots the
deer loses focus for a minute and it all
goes to [ __ ] again so number three the
Rick getting eaten fake out subheading
remember the dumpster so it's okay if
you took the bait so to speak and
thought that Rick might be dead because
they really put you in Michonne said
they really want you to feel the
psychosis that she falls into with that
crazy music and how it zooms in on her
face when she's walking up like oh my
god Rick's being eaten this is terrible
I don't know what to do until wait for
it he barrels out of that box so of
course Rick is not going to die in some
one-off episode this wasn't even a negan
episode there's no way they're going to
let him die like that
remember the dumpster even the Glenn
episode had a bigger climax than this
episode so whatever I don't get really
upset when they pull twist like that
because you see it coming a mile away
like there's no way that he's going to
die so he's going to come barreling out
that's probably the deer that's getting
eaten so you know your mind just jumps
through the hoops but they finally gets
a gun sort of recommit to the cause like
yeah we're definitely going to lose
people but it's going to be
that because we're moving towards a
better future for everyone else so even
if I die you can go on so that's when he
tells him is shown that you are capable
of leading this group without me it
doesn't have to be me
even though I don't think they're going
to kill Rick I think they're just
setting Michonne up for more of a
leadership arc like she's always worked
hand-in-hand with Rick but she's always
kind of been his sidekick I think they
just want to show that she can be a
really good leader herself too whereas
you know remember where we picked up
with her in season 3 she was just this
badass with a samurai sword a total
outsider did not really enjoy the
company of other people cut to now where
she's almost like the mom in this new
family unit with Rick so of all the
characters on The Walking Dead she's had
one of the biggest character arcs now
this is just the progression of that but
they take the guns back to Jadis haggle
over more they need to get more gun so
it just come to the point where Tara
finally has to come clean and say look I
think I know where some more guns are so
that's where we queue up Oceanside and
we're in episode 12 there's only four
more episodes left this season so
they're going to have to get there
pretty quickly but number one my
favorite scene from the episode is
Rosita getting so fed up at not being
able to find more guns that she takes
one gun and goes to Sasha and they form
the sort of pseudo Walking Dead Suicide
Squad they're going to go on a mission
to kill negan from which they are pretty
sure they're not going to come back from
they have a map from Jesus Daryl told
them about the layout of the inside so
they're going to try and run a ninja hit
on him but who thinks that negan is
going to go down that easy it is all
going to go sideways
anytime somebody goes rogue on the
walking dead is when things go badly
Rick has this real elaborate plan
they're going to get the guns they're
going to get all these groups together
then they're going to try and fight them
what kind of crazy wrench is Rosita
going to throw in that by trying to kill
negan on her own with Sasha even though
she says I get to take the hit and she
gives her the guns that looked just like
the one that she was using last season
and the one that Abraham used to use so
it's very symbolic her giving her this
kind of weapon so even if it does go
badly it is going to be fantastic to
watch I totally love it when characters
go off the rails like this no matter
what you think is going to happen to the
negan character even if you've read the
comics and you think it's going to go
down differently it's just so much fun
to watch people be this crazy so let me
know what was your favorite
from the episode and what do you think
is going to happen which is crazy Rosita
plan the big stuff that's happening in
the next couple days I'll be posting my
Logan Easter eggs I'll be doing more
Deadpool's they'll be more flash so
congratulations to James Johnson you win
last week's giveaway please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details whole
bunch more comic-book stuff coming up in
the next couple days well you guys wait
for that you can click here for my Logan
review video and you can click here for
that Game of Thrones teaser thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video